From the biggest stadiums To the coziest holes in the wall From house parties to porch hangs to pride celebrations From your favorite fuss shop to your local Indian spot From noodle bars to sports bars to salsa bars There's a Molson with your name on it Canadian ultra XL
从最大的体育场到最舒适的街角小店，从家庭派对、门廊聚会到骄傲大游行，从你最爱的唱片店到当地的印度餐厅，从面条吧、运动吧到莎莎舞吧，总有一款美乐啤酒为你而开，加拿大超大罐。
Molson Everyone in Must be legal drinking age Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents if you feel at any time you need support Please contact your local crisis center for suggested phone numbers for confidential support Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website The Young students of the cool ball learning center in Pennsylvania were due to arrive any minute
美乐啤酒，每个人都必须达到法定饮酒年龄。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件，如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心，获取建议的保密支持电话号码。请在您的应用程序上或我们的网站上查看本集节目的节目说明。宾夕法尼亚州库尔鲍尔学习中心的小学生们随时都可能到达。
Shortly beforehand a teacher entered the school's main entrance and stumbled across an odd scene Scattered on the ground by the front doors were multiple sealed envelopes addressed to the principal More were found throughout the school grounds haphazardly thrown on the lawn on the concrete paths and in bushes They were unstamped with no return details Each envelope contained a copy of the same type written letter Littered with grammatical errors and profanities. It was scathing of a member of staff and her teaching ability It also alleged that she brought cannabis onto school property quote Then showed it in the faculty room just like it was a big joke
在此之前不久，一名老师进入了学校的正门，无意中发现了一幕奇怪的场景。前门附近的地上散落着多封收件人是校长的未拆封信件。在学校的其他地方也发现了更多信件，它们被胡乱扔在草坪上、混凝土小路上和灌木丛中。这些信件都没有贴邮票，也没有回信地址。每个信件都包含一份内容相同的打字信件复印件，里面充斥着语法错误和脏话。信中严厉批评了一名教职员工及其教学能力。信中还指称她将大麻带到学校财产上，引用原话：“然后就像开个大玩笑一样在教工休息室里拿出来展示。”
The principal summoned the teacher at the center of the letters allegations Joanne chambers had been employed as a grade one teacher at cool ball elementary for four years She arrived in mid 1989 with glowing reviews from her previous school where she was praised for her professionalism and organizational skills Joanne was stunned by the letter Given its contents focused on her work It appeared as though it had been written by either a member of cool ball staff or someone connected to the school But as far as Joanne was concerned
校长召集了信件矛头所指的老师。琼·钱伯斯在库尔鲍尔小学担任四年的一年级老师。她于1989年中期来到这里，前学校对她赞誉有加，表扬她的专业精神和组织能力。琼被这封信惊呆了。鉴于信的内容主要针对她的工作，这看起来像是库尔鲍尔的工作人员或与学校有联系的人写的。但就琼所知，
She was embraced by the school community and had a good rapport with her colleagues Her somewhat unconventional methods of teaching involved dancing and singing making her popular with students and parents alike Other staff members seemingly embraced her playful nature In the warmer months Joanne would stage water balloon fights with the school administrators to the delight of her students Respected and well-regarded Joanne was nothing like the letters author depicted Joanne assumed that the letters had been sent by someone out of jealousy as a nasty prank She hoped the author would come forward so they could resolve the matter But whoever was responsible remained anonymous
她受到了学校社区的接纳，与同事关系融洽。她有些非传统的教学方法包括唱歌跳舞，这使她在学生和家长中很受欢迎。其他教职员工似乎也很喜欢她顽皮的性格。在较暖和的月份，琼会与学校管理员进行水气球大战，让她的学生们欣喜不已。受人尊敬、口碑极佳的琼与信件作者所描述的形象判若两人。琼以为这些信件是出于嫉妒的恶作剧。她希望作者能站出来，这样他们就能解决这个问题。但不管是谁干的，一直匿名。
No More letters started appearing around the school over the coming weeks and months Shaved into the teacher's mail slots in the faculty room was a letter accusing Joanne of being an alcoholic and drinking in the classroom On March 14 1994 Joanne opened the drawer to her classroom desk to find an empty bottle of whiskey inside While looking for anything else out of the ordinary she noticed the framed portrait of her and her son had been stolen from her desk Up until this point the harassment had been confined to the school grounds However, it wasn't long before Joanne started receiving hang-up phone calls and letters arriving on her doorstep at home The letters were becoming threatening
在随后的几周和几个月里，更多的信件开始出现在学校周围。教工休息室里老师的信箱缝隙里被刻出了一封信，指控琼是个酒鬼，在教室里喝酒。1994年3月14日，琼打开她教室课桌的抽屉，发现里面有一个空威士忌瓶。在寻找其他异常情况时，她注意到桌上她和儿子的带框照片被偷了。在此之前，骚扰仅限于学校范围内。然而，没过多久，琼就开始接到骚扰电话，家里也收到了信件。这些信件变得越来越具有威胁性。
One read I Can get you in one try no one will ever prove it They may not think so, but I'm smarter than all of you you stupid bitch Another threatened to poison Joanne You really are a clueless bitch. I had four chances to drug your coffee this week or did I drug your coffee? Bitch you make me sick Joanne would not be intimidated by her unknown detractor and continued teaching at the cool ball learning center Exactly one month after finding the whiskey bottle in her desk drawer Joanne stood behind the same desk to begin teaching for the day
其中一封写道：“我一次就能搞定你，没人能证明。他们可能不这么认为，但我比你们所有人都聪明，你这个愚蠢的婊子。”另一封威胁要毒害琼：“你真的是个毫无头脑的婊子。我这星期有四次机会在你的咖啡里下药，还是说我已经下药了？婊子，你让我作呕。”琼没有被她未知的诋毁者吓倒，继续在库尔鲍尔学习中心教书。在办公桌抽屉里发现威士忌瓶正好一个月后，琼站在同一张办公桌后面开始当天的教学。
She was wearing a long dress and as she sat down in her chair Joanne smoothed the fabric out from under her thighs She then felt something unpleasant Feces had been smeared all over her seat Joanne complained to the cool boy township police department and chief Anthony flugel was assigned to the case Joanne relayed the past incidents including the one involving the photograph taken from her school desk A letter had also been sent to the school administrators parents and even taped to a local store door It depicted a pornographic image of three naked women in a bathtub Joanne's face had been cut from the photo on her desk and superimposed onto the face of one of the women
她穿着一条长裙，当她坐在椅子上时，琼把大腿下的布料抚平。然后她感到很不舒服。座位上涂满了粪便。琼向库尔鲍尔镇警察局投诉，安东尼·弗卢格警长被指派负责此案。琼转述了过去的事件，包括从学校课桌上偷走照片的那起事件。一封信还被寄给了学校管理员、家长，甚至贴在了一张当地商店的门上。上面描绘了一张浴缸里三个裸体女性的色情图片。琼的脸从她桌上的照片上被剪下来，贴在其中一个女性的脸上面。
Written alongside it using a stencil were the words It's not over You die Chief flugel agreed that Joanne was likely being targeted by someone in the school system A hidden camera was placed in her classroom to try and catch the culprit red-handed The threatening letters were sent to an FBI lab in Virginia who were able to extract partial prints from some of the envelopes But not enough to make a match Joanne's fellow teachers were called to a meeting where it was explained that police were investigating the attacks against her
旁边用模板写着：“还没结束，你会死。”弗卢格警长同意，琼很可能是学校系统中的某个人盯上了。她的教室里被安放了一个隐藏摄像头，试图当场抓获罪魁祸首。这些威胁信被送到弗吉尼亚州的联邦调查局实验室，他们能够从一些信封上提取部分指纹，但不足以进行匹配。琼的同事们被召集到一个会议上，会上解释说警察正在调查针对她的袭击事件。
If the perpetrator was among them, it was hoped this information would scare them into stopping Chief Anthony flugel examined the footage taken from the hidden camera in Joanne's classroom At 8.18 one morning before the commencement of class the camera captured something peculiar Joanne could be seen talking to a fellow teacher After collecting a few items the pair left the classroom A few moments later the other teacher returned to the empty room She took something from Joanne's desk and walked out of the room with it It was fellow first grade teacher Paula Norocchi and she had taken Joanne's coffee cup
如果肇事者在他们中间，希望这些信息能吓得他们收手。安东尼·弗卢格警长检查了琼教室里隐藏摄像头拍摄的画面。一天早上上课前8点18分，摄像头拍到了奇怪的一幕。可以看到琼正在和另一位老师交谈。收集了几件物品后，两人离开了教室。片刻之后，另一位老师回到了空无一人的房间。她从琼的桌子上拿走了一样东西，拿着它走出了房间。那是同为一年级老师的保拉·诺罗奇，她拿走了琼的咖啡杯。
Described by colleagues as diplomatic, honest and peaceful Paula Norocchi had been a teacher in the Monroe County School District for 20 years Unlike Joanne who was outgoing and searched for fun and creative ways to teach her class Paula was quiet, favoured traditional teaching methods and followed procedures by the book The pair differed not only in personality but in appearance Joanne was tore with green eyes and blonde hair that she wore in loose locks to her shoulders While Paula was of a slight build with hazel eyes and short brown hair she styled into a perm Caring and professional Paula Norocchi was popular with parents and students
同事们形容保拉·诺罗奇外交、诚实、平和，她在门罗县学区当了20年老师。与外向、寻找有趣和创造性教学方法的琼不同，保拉很安静，喜欢传统的教学方法，按规矩办事。两人不仅性格迥异，外表也不同。琼身材高挑，绿眼睛，金发披肩；而保拉身材娇小，榛色眼睛，留着烫发风格的短棕色头发。保拉富有同情心且专业，在家长和学生中很受欢迎。
Like Joanne she received positive feedback from her superiors However other staff had commented that they thought Paula was jealous of Joanne's reputation as the fun teacher As reported in the newspaper The Times Tribune another incident also aroused suspicion amongst the teaching staff In one of the threatening letters sent to Joanne a reference was made regarding the school superintendent and his similarity to German commander Colonel Klink in the television series Hogan's Heroes An employee recalled a conversation with Paula Norocchi in which she made this exact comparison Paula denied any involvement in the attacks against Joanne Chambers With no evidence connecting her to the crimes she was allowed to continue teaching
像琼一样，她得到了上级的好评。然而，其他员工评论说，他们认为保拉嫉妒琼作为有趣老师的声誉。正如《纪事论坛报》所报道的，另一起事件也在教职员工中引起了怀疑。在寄给琼的一封威胁信中，提到了学校总监以及他与电视剧《霍根英雄》中的德国指挥官克林K上校的相似之处。一名员工回忆起与保拉·诺罗奇的对话，她在对话中做了完全相同的比较。保拉否认参与了针对琼·钱伯斯的袭击。由于没有证据将她与罪行联系起来，她被允许继续教书。
However Paula was snubbed by fellow teachers who were convinced of her guilt and sent to work in a different building Joanne was transferred to another school for her own safety while the investigation was ongoing On May 6, 1994 Joanne and Paula were subjected to polygraph tests The purpose in testing Joanne was to rule out that she was embellishing any of the vile acts she had been subjected to Joanne's answers indicated that she was being truthful During Paula's polygraph test she was asked Were you involved with making or sending any of the threatening letters? Paula, who voluntarily submitted to the polygraph in the hopes it would clear her name, answered, No
然而，保拉遭到坚信她有罪的同事们的冷落，并被派往另一栋楼工作。为了自身安全，琼在调查期间被调到另一所学校。1994年5月6日，琼和保拉接受了测谎仪测试。测试琼的目的是排除她夸大了她所遭受的任何恶劣行为的可能性。琼的回答表明她在说实话。在保拉的测谎测试中，她被问到：“你是否参与制作或发送了任何威胁信？”保拉自愿接受测谎，希望以此洗清罪名，她回答：“没有。”
The polygraph examiner concluded she was being deceitful Paula maintained her innocence. She told Chief Anthony Flugel I don't think I am doing it. If I am, I don't know it He informed Paula that she was a strong suspect and it would be in her best interests to come forward and stop the harassment Paula replied, You'll never prove it was me Even though Chief Flugel suspected Paula from the outset, a lack of proof left her free to leave A search of Paula's home was undertaken and a typewriter and various stationery supplies such as paper and envelopes were taken into evidence On May 27, 1994 Joanne was leaving work after a long day
测谎仪检查员得出结论，她在撒谎。保拉坚称自己无辜。她告诉安东尼·弗卢格警长：“我认为我没有做。如果我做了，我不知道。”他通知保拉她是主要嫌疑人，主动站出来制止骚扰对她最有利。保拉回答：“你永远无法证明是我干的。”尽管弗卢格警长从一开始就怀疑保拉，但由于缺乏证据，她还是得以离开。对保拉的家进行了搜查，一台打字机和纸张、信封等各种文具用品被作为证据带走。1994年5月27日，琼结束了漫长的一天工作准备离开。
As she went to open the driver's side door to her car, she recoiled Something sharp had cut her finger She discovered a razor blade affixed to the underside of the handle A few days later, Joanne received a letter that read, You're Sliced One day, a package was found at the front door of Joanne's new school It was a small box wrapped in pink paper Inside, was a Barbie doll It was wearing a blue dress similar to one Joanne often wore
当她去拉开汽车驾驶员侧的车门时，她本能地缩回了手。某种锋利的东西割破了她的手指。她发现在车门把手的下方贴着一枚剃须刀片。几天后，琼收到一封信，上面写着：“你被切片了。”一天，在琼的新学校前门发现了一个包裹。这是一个用粉红色纸包裹的小盒子。里面是一个芭比娃娃。它穿着一件蓝色裙子，类似于琼经常穿的那件。
The Barbie's blonde hair had been cut to shoulder length and style Into loose locks In the doll's neck was a razor blade Red paint surrounded the blade and dripped down the doll's chest A few months passed with no new threats In November 1994, Joanne was travelling along Interstate 380 It was daytime and a route that she travelled often As she drove, Joanne gazed up to her rear view mirror
芭比娃娃的金发被剪到肩长，梳成了披肩卷发。娃娃的脖子里插着一颗剃须刀片。红色油漆环绕着刀片，顺着娃娃的胸口往下滴落。几个月过去了，没有出现新的威胁。1994年11月，琼行驶在380号州际公路上。那是白天，是她经常走的一条路线。开着车，琼抬头看了看后视镜。
A car behind her was gaining speed It pulled up alongside her and swerved suddenly, running Joanne off the road Almost like it was occurring in some places Joanne was able to brake and pull over to safety While simultaneously getting a glimpse of the driver who had risked both their lives staging the dangerous manoeuvre It was Paula Norrocke Joanne later described the incident in the series Medical Detectives Paula's looking right at her
她后面的一辆车正在加速。它开到她旁边，突然猛打方向盘，把琼逼出了路面。就像在某些地方发生的一样，琼能够刹车并安全靠边停车。同时瞥了一眼冒着生命危险做出这种危险 maneuvers 的司机。那是保拉·诺罗基。琼后来在《法医神探》系列中描述了这一事件：“保拉正看着她。”
I will never forget that look By January 1995, the Monroe County District Attorney's Office had enough evidence to arrest Paula Norrocke She was taken from her first grade class by police and charged with recklessly endangering the life of Joanne Chambers by trying to run her off the road She also faced 78 counts of stalking, 24 counts of making terroristic threats and 2 counts of assault Still maintaining her innocence, Paula was released on bail She and her husband hired a private detective, James Anderson to investigate the charges against her
“我永远不会忘记那个眼神。”到1995年1月，门罗县地方检察官办公室有足够的证据逮捕保拉·诺罗基。她被警察从一年级课堂带走，被指控试图将琼·钱伯斯逼出路面，从而鲁莽危害其生命安全。她还面临78项跟踪罪、24项发出恐怖威胁罪和2项袭击罪。保拉坚称自己无辜，获得保释。她和丈夫聘请了私家侦探詹姆斯·安德森来调查对她的指控。
Although skeptical of her innocence, James agreed to take on the case Given that the letters sent to Joanne and the Cool Ball Learning Center formed a large part of the prosecution's case Paula suggested that the evidence be sent for DNA testing James warned her about proceeding, explaining that this could have an adverse effect on her case if her DNA was found on any of the letters Paula maintained she had nothing to hide She spent approximately $7,000 of her own money to have the testing done Carefully lifting three stamps off one of the envelopes, a DNA-typing expert was able to extract DNA from saliva on stamps affixed to the envelope It was not a match to Paula Norrocke
尽管对她的清白持怀疑态度，詹姆斯还是同意接手这个案子。鉴于寄给琼和库尔鲍尔学习中心的信件构成了控方证据的大部分，保拉建议将证据送去进行DNA检测。詹姆斯警告她不要这样做，并解释说如果在任何信件上发现她的DNA，这可能会对她的案件产生不利影响。保拉坚称她没有什么好隐瞒的。她自费大约7000美元进行了检测。DNA分型专家小心翼翼地从其中一个信封上揭下三张邮票，成功从贴在信封上的邮票唾液中提取了DNA。这与保拉·诺罗基不匹配。
Paula was also able to extract DNA from the envelopes She was also able to extract DNA from the envelopes She was also able to extract DNA from the envelopes It was not a match to Paula Norrocke Acting on a hunch, private investigator James Anderson went to Joanne Chambers' home Under the cover of darkness, he rummaged through her garbage bins on the curbside for collection Finding a few tissues and a used ear swab, James took the items and replaced the lid on the bin He arranged for a DNA profile to be extracted from the discarded items
保拉还能够从信封中提取DNA。她还能够从信封中提取DNA。她还能够从信封中提取DNA。这与保拉·诺罗基不匹配。私家侦探詹姆斯·安德森凭着直觉来到了琼·钱伯斯的家。在夜色的掩护下，他在路边的垃圾桶里翻找待收的垃圾。找到了几张纸巾和一根用过的棉签，詹姆斯拿走了这些物品，并盖上了垃圾桶盖子。他安排从丢弃的物品中提取DNA图谱。
A male sample, presumably Joanne's husband or son, and a female sample were uncovered The female sample was determined to be that of Joanne Chambers It was compared to the DNA profile from the postage stamps It was a complete match Given this development, Paula's defense lawyer argued for the charges to be dropped against his client immediately His request was denied Joanne was nonchalant when confronted about her DNA being found on the stamps She voluntarily submitted to a blood test for further DNA testing to be done
发现了一个男性样本（推测是琼的丈夫或儿子）和一个女性样本。经确定，女性样本属于琼·钱伯斯。将其与邮票上的DNA图谱进行对比，完全吻合。鉴于这一进展，保拉的辩护律师立即要求撤销对他的当事人的指控。他的请求被拒绝了。当被问及在邮票上发现她的DNA时，琼表现得很冷漠。她自愿提供血样以便进行进一步的DNA检测。
Joanne did not deny it was her DNA and had an explanation as to how it had gotten there She explained that during the course of the investigation, she had been at the police station for questioning She had been left alone with a stack of the threatening letters on the table in front of her Joanne picked up an envelope to examine it Her handling caused the stamps to fall off Joanne admitted she tried to reaffix the stamps herself with saliva But when that failed, she stuck them back on with a glue stick she kept in her handbag The trial against Paula Norrocke began on January 15, 1996
琼没有否认那是她的DNA，并对它是如何到达那里的做出了解释。她解释说，在调查过程中，她曾在警察局接受讯问。她被单独留在桌子前，桌上有一叠威胁信。琼拿起一个信封端详。她的触碰导致邮票掉了下来。琼承认她试图用唾液重新贴上邮票，但失败后，她用手提包里的一支胶棒把它们粘了回去。对保拉·诺罗基的审判于1996年1月15日开始。
After an early preliminary hearing determined there was enough evidence for her to stand trial Court proceedings had to be postponed several times due to blizzards and flood warnings On his way into court, Paula's defense lawyer joked to local police that she had been found Paula's defense lawyer joked to local newspaper The Morning Call We've encountered blizzards and floods and I hope that pestilence and locusts aren't far behind Court Room No. 4 was packed with journalists as well as members of the general public who were intrigued by the unusual case If found guilty, Paula Norrocke faced a maximum of five years jail time and a $10,000 fine for each count She listened attentively to testimony from those who examined the DNA evidence on the letters and envelopes
在初审确定有足够证据让她接受审判后，由于暴风雪和洪水预警，法庭审理程序不得不推迟了好几次。在前往法院的路上，保拉的辩护律师开玩笑地对当地警察说她已经被找到了。保拉的辩护律师对当地报纸《晨报》开玩笑说：“我们遇到了暴风雪和洪水，我希望瘟疫和蝗虫不会太远。”4号法庭挤满了记者以及对这起不寻常案件感兴趣的公众。如果被判有罪，保拉·诺罗基每项指控将面临最高五年的监禁和1万美元的罚款。她专心聆听了检查信件和信封上DNA证据的人员的证词。
Another DNA sample was extracted from adhesive used to seal an envelope The sample wasn't strong enough to obtain a full profile as had been done with the postage stamps However, it was complete enough to rule out Paula Norrocke as the source Joanne Chambers could not be excluded Speaking calmly and concisely, Paula Norrocke testified that she believed Joanne was harassing herself in an attempt to frame her and to gain attention Paula had an explanation for retrieving the coffee cup from Joanne's desk She stated that Joanne had asked her to get it for her It was determined that Paula had been subjected to a different, more rigorous polygraph test than Joanne
从用于封信封的粘合剂中提取了另一个DNA样本。该样本不够强大，无法像邮票那样获得完整的图谱。然而，它足够完整，可以排除保拉·诺罗基作为来源。琼·钱伯斯无法被排除。保拉·诺罗基平静而简练地作证说，她认为琼一直在骚扰自己，企图陷害她并博取关注。保拉对从琼的桌子上拿走咖啡杯做出了解释。她表示是琼让她帮拿的。经确定，保拉接受了与琼不同、更严格的测谎测试。
Furthermore, her comment to Chief Anthony Flugel, you'll never prove it was me, had been taken entirely out of context then used against her The jury heard testimony from former employees who described Paula's exemplary behaviour and teaching ability Analysis of the stationary and typewriter found in Paula's home did not match the letters received by Joanne Joanne's typewriter was never examined A chemist discredited Joanne's allegation that she affixed the stamps back to the envelope with a glue stick as the adhesive would turn a bluish colour under UV light When he examined the stamps, this was not apparent Next, Joanne Chambers took the stand
此外，她对安东尼·弗卢格警长说的“你永远无法证明是我干的”这句话完全被断章取义，然后用来对付她。陪审团听取了前员工的证词，他们描述了保拉的模范行为和教学能力。对在保拉家中发现的文具和打字机的分析与琼收到的信件不符。琼的打字机从未被检查过。一位化学家反驳了琼关于她用胶棒将邮票重新贴在信封上的指控，因为在紫外光下，粘合剂会变成蓝色。当他检查邮票时，这并不明显。接下来，琼·钱伯斯出庭作证。
Her demeanour, her behaviour, and her behaviour were not clear Mina, as she answered questions from the defence, did little to help her cause The morning call reported her testimony as uneven, with replies that ranged from subdued to testy to sarcastic She also rolled her eyes, and courtroom observers noticed that she seemed edgy Mid-trial, the principal of Joanne's former school provoked an audible gasp from the courtroom as he recounted an event from Joanne's earlier career In the early 80s, Joanne had approached him asking to go home early because she had sat in feces Private investigator James Anderson, hired by Paula Norrocke, had found witnesses who'd worked with Joanne Chambers at this point in her career One witness, Jane Padoe, told the court that she and the six other teachers at the school were summoned to the library for a meeting
她的风度、行为和表现都不明确。米娜在回答辩护方的提问时，对她的处境毫无帮助。《晨报》报道她的证词断断续续，回答从低调到易怒再到讽刺不等。她还翻白眼，法庭观察员注意到她似乎有些急躁。庭审进行到一半时，琼前学校的校长复述了琼早期职业生涯中的一件事，引发了法庭上一阵清晰的惊呼。80年代初，琼曾找到他，要求早退，因为她坐在了粪便上。由保拉·诺罗基聘请的私家侦探詹姆斯·安德森找到了在职业生涯这个阶段与琼·钱伯斯共事过的证人。一位证人简·帕多告诉法庭，她和学校的其他六名老师被召集到图书馆开会。
They were told that Joanne had received harassing phone calls and threats that her house would be burned down Jane said of Joanne She carried tales that weren't true to the superintendent, and she tried to get us in trouble Jane added that she wanted to stay as far away from Joanne Chambers as possible Witness Lois Render, a former teacher, described Chambers as someone who told tall tales One involved Joanne studying to be a nun She said she'd broken her leg after jumping out a window to escape the nuns who were trying to force her to stay at the convent Also remembering that Joanne tried to get other teachers into trouble, Lois described her school as a harmonious place until Chambers came along
他们被告知琼收到了骚扰电话和烧毁她房子的威胁。简对琼评价道：“她向校长搬弄不实之词，并试图让我们陷入麻烦。”简补充说，她想离琼·钱伯斯越远越好。证人露丝·伦德是一名退休教师，她形容钱伯斯是个爱编造离奇故事的人。其中一个故事是琼曾学习当修女。她说她从窗户跳下去逃跑时摔断了腿，因为修女们试图强迫她留在修道院里。露丝还记得琼试图让其他老师惹麻烦，她形容她的学校曾经是一个和谐的地方，直到钱伯斯出现。
Private investigator James Anderson listed 16 occasions where Joanne complained to authorities about anonymous threats prior to the incidents with Paula Norrocke Paula's defense lawyer suggested that Joanne had placed the evidence herself to frame Paula because she hadn't catered to Joanne as other teachers had done Additionally, there were no witnesses who observed Joanne being run off the road by Paula Norrocke Joanne's testimony was the only thing implicating Paula in this event On January 22, 1996, the six men and six women of the jury retired to deliberate They returned to the courtroom less than two hours later Paula Norrocke was found not guilty of all charges The jurors hugged Paula after the trial
私家侦探詹姆斯·安德森列出了在与保拉·诺罗基发生事件之前，琼向当局投诉匿名威胁的16次经历。保拉的辩护律师暗示，琼自己放置了证据来陷害保拉，因为保拉没有像其他老师那样迎合琼。此外，没有目击者看到琼被保拉·诺罗基逼出路面。琼的证词是唯一将保拉牵连到这一事件中的东西。1996年1月22日，六名男陪审员和六名女陪审员退席进行闭门商议。不到两小时后，他们返回法庭。保拉·诺罗基被裁定所有指控不成立。审判结束后，陪审员们拥抱了保拉。
One told her, Our hearts are with you Joanne Chambers slipped from the courtroom quietly, largely ignored by those in attendance Although she was found to not guilty on all charges, Paula Norrocke was still required to attend a school board hearing to determine whether or not she could keep her job Held over a series of nights in early 1997, the hearing was to address charges of immorality, neglect and other school code violations in relation to the case Unlike the criminal trial that required a unanimous verdict, only six of the appointed eight school directors had to find that Paula Norrocke acted immorally and in their election of duty for her to lose her job Mike Eleven, acting as prosecutor on behalf of the school board, opened by saying This case is a most unusual, most tragic case You will hear about 41 profane, threatening, disgusting letters
其中一人对她说：“我们的心与你同在。”琼·钱伯斯静静地溜出法庭，在场的人大多忽视了她。尽管所有指控均被判无罪，但保拉·诺罗基仍被要求出席学校董事会听证会，以决定她是否能保住工作。听证会于1997年初连续几个晚上举行，旨在处理与此案相关的违反道德、疏忽和其他学校规章制度的指控。与需要一致裁决的刑事审判不同，指定的八名学校董事中，只需六名认为保拉·诺罗基行为不道德且玩忽职守，她就会失去工作。代表学校董事会担任检察官的迈克·埃莱文在开场白中说：“这个案子是一个极不寻常、极悲惨的案子。你们将听到41封充满亵渎、威胁、令人作呕的信件。”
You will hear about blood, you will hear about feces, you will hear about razor blades, you will hear about a Barbie doll, you will hear about nude photographs Everyone involved in the case agrees that the stalking incidents happened and that the person responsible should be fired The point of the disagreements with this case is, who did it? Who is responsible for these acts? The hearing largely repeated the information presented at the criminal trial On April 2, 1997, Paula Norrocke was acquitted of the charges against her and permitted to keep her teaching job When the verdict was read, the packed auditorium, opened to the public, cheered for Paula Jeering could be heard at the mention of Joanne Chambers' name But, with no evidence proving she was the cause of the harassment, Joanne was also allowed to keep teaching
你们会听到血，你们会听到粪便，你们会听到剃须刀片，你们会听到一个芭比娃娃，你们会听到裸照。案中所有人都同意跟踪事件确实发生过，肇事者应该被解雇。本案争议的焦点在于，是谁干的？谁应对这些行为负责？听证会大体上重复了刑事审判中提出的信息。1997年4月2日，保拉·诺罗基被判无罪，并获准保留教职。宣判时，向公众开放的座无虚席的礼堂为保拉欢呼。当提到琼·钱伯斯的名字时，可以听到嘘声。但是，由于没有证据证明她是骚扰的根源，琼也被允许继续教书。
In November 2000, Paula Norrocke received a $600,000 settlement from the school district She was also awarded a $25,000 settlement from Joanne Chambers, after seeking compensation for out-of-pocket costs and punitive damages in the course of the trial Paula also sought compensation for defamation from lead detective, Chief Anthony Flugel She alleged he maliciously prosecuted her without probable cause Flugel, who was by this time a lieutenant, refused to settle out of court A federal damage trial commenced in December 2000 Flugel testified that he acted under the direction of the Monroe County District Attorney's Office And there was probable cause at the time to arrest Paula Norrocke
2000年11月，保拉·诺罗基从学区获得了60万美元的和解金。在审判过程中寻求自付费用和惩罚性赔偿的赔偿后，她还获得了一笔来自琼·钱伯斯的25,000美元和解金。保拉还就主侦探安东尼·弗卢格警长对其进行诽谤寻求赔偿。她指控他在没有合理根据的情况下恶意起诉她。当时已升任中尉的弗卢格拒绝庭外和解。联邦损害赔偿审判于2000年12月开始。弗卢格作证说，他是根据门罗县地方检察官办公室的指示行事的，当时有合理根据逮捕保拉·诺罗基。
Paula's defense argued that the arrest and subsequent trial proceeded despite a mountain of growing evidence implicating Joanne Chambers as her own tormentor In a case described by Paula's defense attorney as the strangest he had ever been involved in, Flugel was acquitted of the charge of defamation on December 12, 2000 Both women continued teaching at different schools and had successful careers Paula Norrocke had suffered the fallout of being in the public eye, telling the court at the federal trial that Some people still avoid me But by 2001 Paula was teaching the third grade and it was reported in the morning call that her life had largely returned to normal In 2014, after a celebrated career, Joanne Chambers retired from teaching She obtained the status of a national board certified teacher and had helped hundreds of students learn to read as a specialist teacher for children with dyslexia
保拉的辩护律师辩称，尽管有如山般的证据表明琼·钱伯斯是她自己的折磨者，但逮捕和随后的审判仍在继续。正如保拉的辩护律师所描述的那样，这是他参与过的最奇怪的案件，2000年12月12日，弗卢格被判诽谤罪不成立。两位女性继续在不同的学校教书并取得了成功的职业生涯。保拉·诺罗基承受了身处公众视野的余波，她在联邦审判中告诉法庭：“有些人仍然躲着我。”但到2001年，保拉正在教三年级，据《晨报》报道，她的生活基本恢复了正常。2014年，经过辉煌的职业生涯，琼·钱伯斯从教学生涯中退休。她获得了国家董事会认证教师的身份，并作为儿童诵读困难专科老师帮助数百名学生学会了阅读。
Although it was never determined who was responsible for the harassment of Joanne Chambers, the assaults ceased following the trial Hugh Hutchinson, who represented Chief Anthony Flugel at the federal trial for defamation, told the courtroom Somebody was very clever and very careful Whoever it was You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
尽管从未确定是谁应对针对琼·钱伯斯的骚扰负责，但审判后袭击事件停止了。休·哈钦森在联邦诽谤审判中代表安东尼·弗卢格警长，他在法庭上说：“某人非常聪明，非常小心。无论他是谁……”本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。